hello everyone welcome and thank you for
dialing in for our webinar today this
session is brought to you by seepers
instruments and co-hosted by labroots my
name is Riley lay and I will be
moderating today's session on a closer
look at endotoxin testing platforms
how traditional techniques compared to
recent industry developments and how
ease of use productivity and data
Integrity can be improved
you can expect today's webinar to last
for approximately one hour 45 minutes to
speaking and then be followed by a
15-minute q a session to submit
questions during this presentation
please email them too
riley.leigh at suez.com
by the end of our time today we hope you
feel more comfortable and confident
about making a buying decision for
endotex endotoxin testing platforms
we will now begin with our speaker
introduction I am pleased to introduce
Meg provenzano of Sievers instruments
Meg is a global product manager
specializing in biodection
she's over 10 years of experience in the
bacterial endotoxin testing industry
she has held several positions from
quality control to technical support to
product management
she's customer-centric and enjoys
problem solving Hands-On whether it
comes down to technical issues assay
Assistance or software
Meg majored in Marine Science and
biology at Coastal Carolina University
where she focused on bottlenose dolphin
population research she also assisted in
Marine Mammal stranding rescues and
necropsies
I will now pass this along to make so we
can begin thank you
all right thank you Riley
um as Riley said we're going to take a
closer look at endotoxin testing
platforms today
here's a little overview of the agenda
we'll look at what exactly is endotoxin
and review some of the testing methods
look at some of the pain points of
endotoxin testing today give you an
overview of ours Eclipse bacterial
endotoxin test instrument
look at a method suitability from a case
study and then look at how we can
simplify the bacterial endotoxin testing
and show you a sample validation
overview
so what exactly are endotoxins endotoxin
comes from the outer cell membrane of
gram-negative bacteria and it's
pyrogenic meaning that it can cause
illness when it comes into contact with
blood or cerebral spinal fluid
the endotoxin or lipopolysaccharide
comprises 75 percent of the outer
membrane
you can see it right here
it plays a critical role in the
structural Integrity the physiological
pathogenic and immunogenic immunologic
and nutrient transport functions of the
gram-negative bacteria
it's essential for the gram-negative
bacterial survival
so we did Sievers develop the bacterial
endotoxin testing platform as the
eclipse
well
we developed it to address some of the
pain points of traditional endotoxin
testing
so traditional endocrine tests Solutions
are pretty inefficient and difficult to
run consistently
96 weld plate assays require highly
trained analysts and Labs often have to
utilize specialists
there's also inconsistencies from
analyst to analyst a lot to lot
variability of the lysate due to its
biological nature and also variability
from assay to assay
in addition traditional methods are time
consuming
operation it takes about 45 to 60
minutes to get an assay started while
you're making your standard curve and
Sample dilutions
so time to results
um could be two four hours including
data instances
and sign off
we see with traditional methods and
valid rates of greater than five percent
typically this can definitely vary based
on the lab setup but this is what we
typically see with 96 plates or gel
cloth
foreign with traditional methods there's
a heavy Reliance on the LEL reagent
which can be expensive
um and there's also a desire for
sustainability
in the lab
typically QC analysts
often have lots of samples to test so
there's a desire for improved throughput
in operational efficiency gains
there can be some difficulty in trading
new analysts too it can take a month or
two to become proficient at running the
bacterial endotoxin test
ergonomic concerns are another
um reason why we developed this
with traditional methods there's
hundreds of pipetting steps per assay
which can be greatly reduced using the
eclipse platform
there could be some regulatory ambiguity
in some circumstances
and then with robotics it can be
difficult
to validate them and maintain the
instrument itself
so let me give you an overview of the
Sievers Eclipse platform
the eclipse automates the endotoxin
assay without the complexity of robotics
the assay prep time is less than 10
minutes because there's an embedded
standard curve already on there using
RSE
so no need to create your own standard
curve
it uses a kinetic chromogenic method
with commercially available lysate from
any vendor
and you can substantially reduce the
lysate usage
for 21 stamps we would use one mil
milliliter of lysate compared to 10 mils
on traditional methods 421 samples
there's less than 30 pipe petting steps
to load
you can see I'm a positive product
controls
it's fully compliant with the
pharmacopoeia chapters and also meets
the fda's data Integrity requirements
and 21 CFR part 11.
as you can see the platform components
consist of an incubating
spectrophotometer which can incubate at
37 degrees C
um it can detect the change in optical
density similar to other microplate
readers and the transmits the data to a
software
the software is a customizable
Enterprise solution so there's fully
customizable user permissions it's
compliant with data integrity and 21cfr
part 11.
and also offers a
server installation option which means
that you could have uh
the lab computer with the software on it
and then also a
manager or office computer with the
client installed directing them to the
same server so it allows for easy sign
offs and audit Trail review with
electronic signatures there's also
convenient asset templates
the microplate
is a microfluidic liquid handling
um
plate it's pre-loaded with RSE endotoxin
standards and positive product controls
it also can use the FDA license kinetic
chromogenic Lal
the thing that's not the paper plate is
that it allows for precise measurement
distribution and mixing of samples
standards and Lal there's a one-to-one
sample to lysate ratio which maintains
the same biochemistry as traditional
micro plate readers
foreign
micro plate
it allows automation through embedded
reference standard endotoxin in
microfluidics
so the plate itself is back into 26
segments five for standards and negative
controls and it offers triplicate
standard concentrations at 50. 5 0.5
and 0.005
the control to be run with every plate
as I mentioned you can run up to 21
samples
so each sample port includes positive
product controls and samples in
duplicate
the sample lrw and Lal are pipetted into
the plate through 27 injection ports
each segment splits sample or lrw in
equal amounts into four reaction Wells
for a total of 104
. there's 24 months of stability at room
temperature storage so no need to have a
refrigerator to store the microplates
and there's an ongoing stability study
with a goal of a three-year shelf life
so let's discuss a little bit more about
how the microfluenic plate actually
works
the instrument rotates the plate and
uses centrifugal force to move to
measure liquids while building pressure
each dispensing well has two components
a metering chamber and an overflow
chamber
which allows for pressurization in the
pneumatic chamber
the sample metering chamber
versus the Overflow chamber over here
and the flow
this uh allows flow from metering
chamber to the Overflow chamber and then
here's the LL heater and chamber
so a little bit more about how this
works the instrument slows the plate
down releasing the pressure and
precisely dispenses samples and Lal into
the reaction wells in a one-to-one ratio
so you can see the sampling Chambers in
green with along with the microfluidic
channels that allow the sample to mix
with the Lal into the optical Wells
these are the microfluidic channels for
the L and then you can see the metering
chamber and the Lal overflow Chambers
here
again this allows for precise dispensing
of the samples in Lal to mix in the
optical well
there's a little bit closer view so you
can see the optical well and the sample
and LEL mixed together
and then also the Lal overflow chamber
so the instrument oscillates the
fourth tables and standards are mixed
with the LEL in the reaction Wells the
kinetic chromogenic assay begins
and we'll take as long as traditional
methods depending on the standard curve
that you choose to run
so let's take a look at the eclipse
versus others comparing the eclipse to
gel plot in 96 well plates
so with gel clot
um although it is still kind of
considered the gold standard it is a
qualitative
so yes it does re
um meet Regulatory Compliance is it
consistent and reliable not so much we
definitely see a higher retest rate with
gel clot
um especially when compared to the
eclipse
um
C is
um incredibly low it like I said it
takes
um 90 more Lal to run 21 samples
um whereas the eclipse only uses one
milliliter of lysate
because
God is definitely
um reduced it doesn't take a whole lot
but there is
um something to be said about the cost
the actual cost per test when you
compare uh
and look at your readers
so most expensive test is one that you
have to do twice
data Integrity concerns
with joke lot it's there's no software
involved so most regulatory agencies are
recommending the use of the 4i prince
meaning they
two analysts have to watch as the assay
comes off
um after one hour to make sure that
there's either truly a negative or truly
a positive
um and then it's recorded in a lab
notebook so there's definitely no audit
Trail there
like I mentioned the invalid rate with
gel clot is much higher than with the
eclipse
and there's no software involved with
gel clots so the user experiences
definitely not not there compared to the
eclipse
so let's do a little comparison versus a
traditional 96 well Plate Reader
the there's definitely the regulatory
problems because they both use the same
lysate
um
consistent reliable the 96 well Plate
Reader requires a highly trained analyst
in order to run it
um there's a lot more pipetting steps
needed
a standard curve must be created for
each assay
um or for each day which can increase
the variability between
um analyst or even from assay to assay
not really as efficient as the eclipse
um the 96 well Plate Reader again uses a
10 mil 10 mils of lysate to run 21
samples
the cost is a little bit different than
between the eclipse and the Plate Reader
however The Upfront cost definitely is
worth it to reduce your invalid rate
both of them could be data Integrity
compliant there's uh software out there
that runs the 96 well Plate Reader the
neat identity settings
um again the invalid rate is higher with
a traditional Plate Reader because of
the standard curve creation
um and increase
highlighting steps
the user experience and software is
incredible on the zebra's Eclipse it
offers an easy workflow where some
software for the 96 well Plate Reader
doesn't necessarily
deceiver's eclipse is also simple it's
easy to run it doesn't require a highly
trained analyst to be able to pipette
into the segments
um and it also reduces the opportunity
for errors in contamination which can be
a concern with Knight V6 well plates as
there could be Splash splashing of
pipetting errors and also
increased handling of CSE or RSE
uh using an automated standard curve in
ppcs reduces the set of
89 percent
you can also reduce the risk of
repetitive stress injury with 89 less
pipetting stops
and Innovation we have proven our
commitment to listening to the voice of
customer
in order three this novel microplate and
microplate reader
to
reduce stress on analysts and increase
throughput
and it's a sustainable method where it
reduces the Reliance on the leadership
lysine by 90 percent
Let's uh do a little overview of
compendial chapter chapters and how to
switch endotoxin platforms easily
so some regulatory considerations for an
endotoxin uh tests
it must be uh fully validatable to
demonstrate the valid endotoxin tests
can be carried out on relevant
substances and products this often
includes a procedure for addressing
interference or inhibition and
enhancement
an additional support is for chromogenic
versus turboelectric techniques
you can leverage software that fully
complies with Alcoa Plus data Integrity
guidelines and provides 21 CFR part 11
compliance capabilities including a
reviewable material
some other considerations are that it
must be defundable in an audit by
meeting all requirements detailed in the
harmonized pharmacopias
and also have adequate uptime to
maintain a validated state
so here are some of the uh compliant
compendial requirements based off of the
USP and EP and JP chapters
must have a minimum three-point standard
curve in duplicate
there has to be at least duplicate
negative controls for each assay
uh samples should be run in at least
duplicate as well
there must be positive product controls
in at least duplicate for every sample
and the English qualification
must use a triple kit standard curve
and another requirement is the use of
standardized endotoxin which could be
either RSE or CSE
how does this Eclipse meet all of these
well as I mentioned you can run a
minimum three point standard curve the
standards offered are 50 5 0.5
0.05 and
0.005 and not all of those have to be
utilized for each assay you could easily
run a three-point standard curve if
desired
there are there's a negative control
segment so that a negative control can
be run with each assay
each sample uh
and do plug kit along with the sample
Spike segments and you can perform an
analyst qualification easily through the
software using a triplicate
um standard curve
another consideration is to use
qualified driven consumables
so switching to the eclipse
the Sievers analytical instruments
you must first understand the method
for each sample type so we understand
that some samples may be tested on
kinetochromogenic or in others on
kinetic turbinometric so here's some
scenarios on switching to the eclipse so
the most
uh the easiest would be switching from a
kinetic chromogenic method to the
kinetic chromogenic on the eclipse
because they both utilize a microplate
reader
um switching from kinetic turbo to
metric to kinetic chromogenic and then
switch to chromogenic
regardless of the current state of
testing it is simple to switch to the
Sievers Eclipse bacterial endotoxin
testing platform
so going from Gel plot to kinetic
chromogenic
um
we can see that the gel plot is a
technique that's commonly leveraged for
difficult sample matrices and for legacy
product uh final release
many Labs still use the gel clot
technique for sample types such as water
and are eager to implement so the method
so customers should perform method
suitability testing to confirm that the
samples they wish to convert are
compatible by performing inhibition and
enhancement testing with the kinetic
chromogenic lysate
for samples that do not require dilution
to overcome interfering factors such as
Ultra Pure Water the process is further
simplified because those samples are
tested typically undiluted or meet
for product samples this testing can be
followed by a three lot
revalue
typically the same dilution that works
on gel plot will often work on a kinetic
method but it's always a good idea to
perform an inhibition enhancement screen
uh before validating just to be sure
and that's simple so you guys can see
how easy it is to move from Gel clock to
a kinetic chromogenic method
now we'll talk about moving from a
kinetic turbidometric to a kinetic
chromogenic method
so one
important to understand is why the
turbinometric glycate was chosen in the
first place
from our experts experience and feedback
collected most customers have chosen to
work with the turbidometric formulation
because they want a cost-effective
quantitative
say and it was easy to move from gelat
usually to a kinetic turbineometric
method because they're similar lysates
typically this decision is not made
because there's an incompatibility with
the chromogenic method in Sample types
the Simplicity and efficiency gains
achieved with the eclipse provide an
economical and sustainable option for
quantitative results
should perform method suitability
testing to compare inhibition
enhancement
trigonometric technique and demonstrate
that they can adequately recover
endotoxin with the chromogenic method
it would then determine the delusion
required to overcome interference or
droi
generally was publishing methods or
techniques it is recommended to perform
a three lot revalidation for final
product release testing
and customer customers can leverage the
validation feature in the eclipse
software to test the required number of
lots which is a customizable setting at
their Pace when the samples are
available when complete a clean
validation summary report is provided
for each sample that meets the
established criteria
so there you have it switching from
kinetic turbidometric to kinetic
chromogenic is just as simple
and then the most simple of all is
switching from a kinetic chromogenic
method on traditional 96 well plates or
cartridge based system to kinetic
chromogenic on Eclipse
this is the most direct transition
when maintaining the connect kinetic
chromogenic method the biochemistry or
the reaction between samples standards
and Lal will remain consistent by
maintaining the one-to-one sample to
lysate ratio the ratio verification is
part of the eclipse system validation
process routine maintenance and is a
hard-coded protocol within the eclipse
software
using a validated system a brief Bridge
study can be completed to finalize the
transition
so to do this you could perform
side-by-side testing with the existing
sample preparation which will likely
remain consistent with the Simplicity
and deficiency of assay set up on the
eclipse running a bridge study requires
little additional effort
so nap a little bit and look at a method
suitability case study
so a little bit of the background and
the test plans
the problem that the customer was facing
was inefficient and inconsistent testing
procedure
they were testing with Kinetic
turbineometric on a 96 well plate
took one year of method development for
these samples
they were seeing elevated endotoxin
responses
the dilutions were from one to one
thousand to one to two thousand and
these were required for valid PPC
recovery
so a little bit about the test plans on
the eclipse
if you looked at method suitability
um looked at a glucan contamination
study
and then the final essay to identify the
optimal delusion for each sample which
included
um endotoxin Spike challenges
the tests were run to
0.005 EU per ml
using two chromogenic Lal formulations
and two Eclipse microplate Lots
so you can see here some of the sample
information
so there's three different samples the
endotoxin limit was 700 EU per ml for
each sample the MVD was then 1 to 140
000 and the validated dilution you can
see for each sample in this column
the average
um PPC recovery that we saw and then the
average result
so a little bit more about the
analytical results
suitability seven dilutions of each
sample were run on three microplates
sample three showed signs of glucans
so we successfully rendered an assay
with using endotoxin-specific buffer
Optimal Solutions for samples one and
two were determined
the full spectrum of dilutions run for
sample three were run with buffer with
and without buffer
so we saw for sample one less than 0.005
EU per ml
endotoxin concentration
for sample two approximately 2 EU per ML
and then sample three was between 70 to
100.
here you can see the percent PPC
recovery using lrw as the
um
to reconstitute the lysate
here is the 50 to 200 percent range and
you can see sample three is typically
very high which would indicate a glucan
contamination
here's the PPC recovery with ES
and you can see it's much lower for each
sample
and then here's a graph showing the
recovery for endotoxin challenge spikes
so each sample was challenged with a
known amount of endotoxin concentration
so sample one you can see here sample
two and Sample three and each were able
to recover uh around what they were
spiked at
within the 50 to 200 percent which we
typically see for a biological assay
so conclusions
what does this show us and and what did
this help gain for the customer
well
the customer was able to
gain efficiency and process optimization
based off of the seven assay method
development for the three different
samples
we determined the kinetic chromogenic
was suitable for these sample types
able to automate the test setup which
leads to efficient method suitability
validation and routine endotoxin testing
so where it took 50 minutes per 96 well
plate and the assay setup was about 20
minutes per Eclipse plate
which gave us time to results
um
based off of running two instruments
simultaneously
um so the efficiency for using the
eclipse was much better than using the
96 flow plate the setup time was reduced
and we proved efficiency showing
um with the eclipse versus 96 well
so here we just kind of outline the the
study a little bit the method
suitability again using the three
samples seven dilutions for each three
different micro plates and looking at an
initial characterization then we move to
the glucan study based off of the high
ppcs using the three samples two to
seven dilutions per sample
two microplates and optimized the method
so then we didn't move to the endotox
and challenge part using the three
samples one dilution each two
microplates and confirmed the optimal
dilution for each
so let's do an efficiency comparison
between 96 well plates
and the oops see here that the setup
time was much greater versus the eclipse
down here
because there's no need to create your
own standard curve because the RSE
standards are already embedded on the
plate so that
decreases your setup Titan significantly
which also significantly decreases your
time to results
and then when we compare pipetting steps
you can see that the pipetting steps for
all of the assays combined
were much much higher for the 96 well
plate compared to the eclipse
so the eclipse really only requires 27
um pipetting steps for a 21 sample
um
microplate
so
here's how you can automate and optimize
with centripetal microfluidics
comparison to the 96 well plate platform
endotoxin testing is challenging and
inefficient
there's a manual test setup required for
hundreds of pipetting steps and is
difficult for consistency
manual testing is prone to errors in
costly retests
there's Hands-On time to start each
assay which can be upwards of 45 to 60
Minutes to create your standard curve
and then
um with some other stuff
can we get in the studio or audit Trail
reviews
how is this different than the zebra's
eclipse the Sievers eclipse automates
the full compendium assay setup using an
Enterprise software
so with the
full deal assay setup we have pre-loaded
standards and ppcs so no need to create
your own standard curve
there's a precise microfluidic liquid
handling so the one-to-one ratio from of
sample to lysate is met
the enterprise software as we've
discussed some used a client server
installation you can review data from
any client workstation including
electronic signatures
and there's a dedicated assay audit
trail with a streamlined review and
e-signature process
so results
which is the most important part you can
start an assay in as little as nine
minutes
there's less than 30 pipetting steps so
no strain on the analyst when it comes
to Organics
there's reduced time to results because
of the acid prep time reduction
you can streamline assay data and audit
Trail review
and you remain fully compliant using a
compendial analytical method and using
secure data management
again one vial of LEL for up to 63
samples because for each assay you are
only using one mil of lysate
compared to 10 mils of lysate for a
traditional method
here's another
chart showing that efficiency
comparisons
from the 96 well plate in dark blue to
eclipse in light blue
and this is for 21 samples so you can
see the setup time
for the 96 weld plate takes a lot longer
than this the setup time for the eclipse
here
time to results are minimized because of
the setup time and then you can see here
again the comparison of uh pipe heading
steps for 96 well plate running 21
samples versus the pipetting steps for
the eclipse
so how can the eclipse help you
increase you can increase your
operational efficiency
so essay as we've said you know the
assay prep time is significantly
decreased so what does that mean for you
well this means that up to a 75 increase
in throughput per instrument
you can also gain up to 51 minutes saved
per assay so if you're running for four
assays per day that's three hours and 20
minutes saved so three hours and 20
minutes where you could redeploy labor
and have them do something else
important so this can increase your
efficiency and reduce time to results
foreign
increasing operational efficiency
looking at the pipetting steps so with
less than 30 pipetting steps for a 21
sample assay you can see that the 96
well plate is just so many more
so so what what does this mean to you
means up to 89 reduction in pipetting
steps which reduces the risk for the
analyst of repetitive stress injuries
you can mitigate stack rotation
and simplify training programs so in
order to run an assay on the eclipse the
training program could be significantly
lower in time compared to a 96 well
assay
it takes
probably up to a few months to become
um really good at
and then you can reduce the opportunity
for error and contamination because the
analyst isn't having to make a standard
curve which can reduce
um the opportunity to contaminate your
assay
a lot
you can reduce the horseshoe crab like
say usage so as I've said the eclipse
uses one mil
compared to 10 mils for a 21 sample run
so up to 90 reduction in Lal reagent use
um secure supply chain for LEL because
you could use any of the kinetic
chromogenic glycates on the market
um this way we can sustain the natural
resource of the horseshoe crab for much
longer and again we maintain the
one-to-one sample to lysate ratio
if you have any questions please don't
hesitate to reach out to me
um and now I think we have a few q a
rightly I'll hand it back over to you
awesome thank you so much Meg so these
are a couple of questions that were
submitted previously and throughout the
presentation
let's Dive In
the first question is do you provide
validation support
absolutely
we have a fantastic validation protocol
that are highly trained analysts or
technicians will come in and perform for
you to get you up and running in less
than two days
the next question is can the customer
choose the Lal Source or vendor that's
used in the microplate
they definitely can so all three of the
major kinetic chromogenic manufacturers
are supported through our software
and there's no need for an unlock code
or anything like that to be able to run
different manufacturers
our next question is if the company has
another analytical method different than
chromogenic what validation test do you
suggest to perform to make the
correlation between methods
yeah we can definitely answer that so
um as I mentioned uh switching from
kinetic turbidometric to kinetic
chromogenic or from a gel clot to
kinetic chromogenic is really easily
easy so you would just confirm that
you're already a validated dilution
Works
um with the chromogenic reagent and then
we would recommend running
at least a three lots validation so
running that non-interfering dilution on
three different lots of sample
and the software can help you with that
too there's a validation protocol
already in there
you have two questions left
how much sample volume and how much Lal
volume is needed for each sample
replicate with this platform
the
uh you know what I'm gonna have to get
back to you on that one
no worries
and then for our quiet final question of
this session
how does the eclipse compare to the gel
clot in terms of data integrity
great question so with gel clot there
are a lot of data Integrity gaps
um so as I mentioned using gel clot
typically the results are recorded in a
laboratory notebook
um so there's no
audit Trail for the lab notebook
um
this is sad to say but analysts could
potentially uh write down the incorrect
results just so they don't have to do a
retest there's a lot of room for air in
the gel clot
um if you potentially had too much
coffee one day and your hands were a
little shaky you could
um look at providing a false negative
um so there's a lot of data Integrity
concerns with gel clot additionally
uh regulatory bodies are suggesting
using uh the 4i principle as I mentioned
earlier so this means two analysts uh
have to watch the results as they come
off so that's to analysts time that
you're accounting for for one assay
whereas if you're using the eclipse
or a fully data Integrity uh compliant
so there's an audit Trail there's a
unique username and a password for each
user
um there's electronic signatures so the
reports could be signed off
electronically
um and there's like I said the audit
Trail review is key that way you can
make sure that you are maintaining
um an overview of that assay which as we
are all aware endotoxin testing is
critical for patient safety so if you
can't trust the results or you can't
trust maybe your analysts then we're
putting patients at risk
um by potentially having a false
negative go out there releasing product
um which could cause uh illness or
something like that
awesome thank you so much today Meg
again if you have any additional
questions please reach out to Meg
provenzano or myself
and we will get back to you
all right thank you